yeah hurricane isaiah's or something
like that i don't know if it's a man or
a woman's name
which is good for 2020. so we're not
sure if this hurricane has gender
reassignment surgery
we do know that it's about to rain
[ __ ] piss and [ __ ] down
on new york city and most of the east
coast in about an hour or two um
so yeah so this sandra d is just telling
us what to look for
yeah i mean this is uh there you go put
it back up because that is the most
that is the most racially ambiguous guy
i have seen all year i mean look at that
guy
that guy what is that guy i'm sorry i
don't know
i'm saying his his parents are he has
got a black father and a white mother or
something like
that guy looks like every member of our
staff past and present in one guy
it does that does look like every single
including venatia yeah it just looks
like everybody and one guy tropical
storm
eyes ass i don't know how to say it but
i mean just you know bring out your
umbrella cause you know what what can
you do
frankie beams the girl who burns her
ex-boyfriend's car that thing when she
blew up her face she blamed her
horoscope so v what are we saying what
sign is she
have you seen this before um maybe she's
a scorpio i don't know
squirrel because scorpios are crazy bees
is that what you're saying this is not
that much about horoscopes sorry what
this sounds like some virgo [ __ ] to me
i'm a virgo i want to do this [ __ ]
we're virgos that looks like my jeep
because we were born one day apart me
and you i know
i know we're a couple of virgos you're
august 25th i'm august 26th
and it's just what are we gonna do for
our birthdays cause we can't go to
medieval times this is the first time
i haven't went to the renaissance fair
of medieval times in about 10 years and
i'm a little upset
so v hint i want to go to i want to do
something on zoom that's midi ball
can't we just get matteo lane uh and
have him cook a little
uh tortellini carbonara in your house
again yeah and
since you moved out of your apartment
back in can't we just make it a birthday
slash housewarming party
we could do that yeah actually let me
text mateo right now and say hey [ __ ]
come on the show cook because i told you
when he cooks from for me and
and mike and his wife nicole and the
baby i mean the food is fantastic and
the kids so supremely talented
it's actually like uh it's hard to take
how talented that kid is
yeah because you need another
housewarming party you bought this
apartment twice
yeah bought it twice yeah so this is you
gotta have another housewarming party
let's get matteo over there let's get
joey come on
let's have a full [ __ ] make rose
we'll all make rose we'll just pour red
and and white wine into a thing mix it
and then just put on the 1975
and turn that living room with those
cute west elm stools
into a full-fledged straight guy's gotta
act gay party i gotta go because i gotta
go move my car
because make no mistake alton side
parking is back [ __ ] you de blasio
[ __ ] you de blasio [ __ ] you
get him out we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
an episode of our morning show wampa in
the morning it's the morning show with
fumare bed head all that it's a little
bump of coke to start your day me and
chris the history hyenas
we do the show live monday through
friday
9 a.m eastern if you want to watch it
live
or get access to it every day go join at
patreon.com
bay ridge boys it's our channel sign up
at the lowest tier level till july 1st
and then it changes to the 10 level
either way go
now go now